antonio brown
resolved the civil lawsuit for sexual
assault and rape that was filed against
him september of 2019.
it contributed to his very short stint
in new england and it also contributed
to him not playing for anyone else in
2019 because
teams weren't sure whether or not he was
going to land on the commissioner
exemplist then last year
when he was suspended eight games for
other misconduct the nfl took no action
regarding this allegation in a civil
lawsuit of sexual assault and rape
the case has been settled the case is
over
it never should have been filed frankly
he should have settled it before it ever
got to that point it wouldn't have
derailed his career in 2019
but now that it's over chris i think it
makes it more likely he'll be back this
year
because if that case hadn't been settled
at some point he was going to have to
testify under oath
and based upon how his testimony under
oath went off the rails in that lawsuit
regarding him allegedly trashing an
apartment in miami right it could have
gone off the rails
it could have gotten him suspended if
you go to trial and you lose
the nfl could have swooped in they
basically left the door open and they
say the door is still open
the matter's still under review but now
that case is settled there's not going
to be any new evidence yeah there's not
going to be any new developments
i suspect they ultimately won't do
anything about this specific allegation
against antonio brown no i don't think
so either and i think you made the case
too last year about you know how he's
kind of
served his suspension anyways with you
know some of the other issues and
everything like that so it's like he's
got some games in the bank
for his what he served for the nfl who
was probably a hair too harsh on him to
begin with and
and some of that so the the big question
to me
is with antonio brown is it gonna be
who's it gonna be
that's all i that's what i wanna know
who's it gonna be i do think this will
open up the door
finally for some more teams to feel
comfortable about getting involved in
the antonio brown
you know attraction and maybe getting
him on their football team
uh so i i i don't know i get the feeling
that the bucks would like to kind of
move on that's just my feeling
i and then again i don't know that i'm
reading between the lines
i just feel like there hasn't been any
aggressive talk there out of the
buccaneers organization that way
and and i guess in my heart of hearts i
think we're going to see antonio brown
on a new team it's just i wonder what
he'll get offered out there on the free
agent market
i know that gm jason light downplayed
the connection between the lawsuit and
the lack of a contract for antonio brown
frankly i think the connection is
stronger than he would acknowledge
now that the lawsuit's cleared away
maybe it does open the door for
something other than an offer that they
know he won't accept
the seahawks thanks to russell wilson
continue to be in the mix
i don't think the organization wants
antonio brown even if russell wilson
does same thing with baltimore
lamar jackson hollywood brown last year
stumping publicly for antonio brown
ravens
didn't want and what'd they do they went
out and got dez bryant instead as kind
of a peace offering
when they didn't pursue the guy that
lamar and hollywood wanted
so i i think the bucks continue to be
the favorite
and uh we'll see what happens and one
last point chris just so we're clear on
what my belief was last year
because the league refused to say
whether or not he'd be on the
commissioner exemplist in 2019
he served a 14-game unpaid suspension
right that's so that to me should count
for something and that's why i think
they should close the door on it it
should be over
he should be free and clear allowed to
come back pending any further
misconduct in which he could engage to
his credit he has stayed out of trouble
for months now based on 2019 i never
would have thought that would happen
here's what's going to happen now quick
break more pft live right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports